[Musique]
bien le bonjour chez vous aujourd'hui
nous sommes dans la ville de thiers
situé entre moscou et saint pétersbourg
à près de 180 km de la capitale elle a
été fondée en 1635 c'est une des plus
anciennes villes du pays
elle était autrefois un important centre
politique et commerciale petit à petit
tiers a perdu de l'influx ans au profit
de moscou
et ce n'est qu'au xviiie siècle après la
fondation de saint pétersbourg et son
développement rapide qu'elle a regagné
de l'importance est venue une des
principales étapes entre ces deux villes
elle compte aujourd'hui près de 400
mille habitants
pierre a été plusieurs fois pillée et
ruiné mais la ville a surtout souffert
d'un terrible incendie au xviiie siècle
catherine de l'impératrice régnante
ordonne alors la reconstruction de la
ville
les architectes de saint pétersbourg ont
essayé de reconstruire un petit modèle
de la capitale
[Musique]
lors de la seconde guerre mondiale la
ville est occupée par les allemands
aient subi de nouveaux dégâts
seuls quelques édifices de l'époque de
catherine deux sont resté authentique
[Musique]
m
l'un de ses bâtiments abritent
aujourd'hui l'hôpital régional pour
enfants c'est ici que nous allons
rencontrer notre invité il est chef du
service de neurochirurgie à l'hôpital il
est aussi neurochirurgien pour enfants
ils s'appellent les ennuis en gamme
il est camerounais allons faire sa
connaissance
[Musique]
mais oh oui ça me fait plaisir de te
rencontrer
bonjour fuite en avant de venir à thiers
alors tu peux me dire un petit peu bon
je crois qu'on va voir ton l'hôpital
quel est ton rôle je suis mais décembre
au chirurgien
oui je suis chef de service du
département de neuro chirurgie
pédiatrique dans cet hôpital donc
carrément chefs de service les autres et
pour les enfants en plus d'accord en ce
moment comment ça se passait ce qu'on
peut regarder l'hôpital il ya des
restrictions
comment ça se passe lui à cause du coup
vite et a trop il ya une très grande
restriction mais je vais essayer on se
protège en mai des masses que tout est
ok je nous montrer ça oui juste un petit
train tout petit peu aller à novi
remercie pour respecter toutes les
règles sanitaires
j'ai pris moi même la caméra et j'ai
suivi les ont dans l'hôpital
[Musique]
ça c'est blocs opératoires c'est là où
tout se passe et ça en fait nous nous
prononcerons mais c'est un brin perdus
et ici ici on peut pas y aller parce que
tout est stérile ou l'hystérie on sait
combien d'opérations tu fais par jour à
peu près aussi eu deux opérations aux
personnes âgées consomment chez lui ça
prend beaucoup de temps des opérations
bhoutan s'est uni avec un coup de coude
au classement il ya des opérations qui
peignent tu ne pouvais pas jouer en cinq
ans des tubes à essai ça prend du temps
maximum de temps sur une opération
il n'y a pas de maxime henry avec vos
positions que j'ai fait sept heures de
temps cette heure je dois rester
concentré pendant sept heures et une
france que tu vois il prend des risques
et d'endesa compliqué 150 beaucoup de
temps ça fait combien de temps que tu es
chef du département
c'est ce qu'on t'a offert on t'a proposé
ses services a dû être une grande joie
non j'imagine ça il n'y avait pas de
service neurochirurgie
d'accord je suis le premier chef de
service
combien de combien de gens travaillent
pour toi je pense que si cette machine
vient beaucoup d'autres gens c'est tout
con quand c'est fini c'est pour foncer
un réfectoire
c'est simple et thierry pourquoi ici on
voit on c'est là où il c'est là où ils
peuvent manger c'est là où il reçoit ici
il joue un peu
je suis l'exemple tous les enfants dont
le temps quand ils sont ici visés au
grand hall de ses coordonnées à et même
des poches des petits dessins et a même
je voyais il ya des poèmes il ya
plaindre c'est toi ce lundi donc les
ondes patricot vite ici c'est comme un
tableau live on conseille si il faut
bien qu'ils pensent à autre chose de
toute façon les enfants et je vois donc
y est on c'est un cabinet ya marqué lyon
patrick au but
nous avons laissé lyon préparé son
opération le cas d'aujourd'hui n'est pas
rare un adolescent de 17 ans qui souffre
d'épilepsie depuis trois ans il a été
détecté une tumeur importante dans le
lobe temporal qu'il va falloir enlever
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
l'opération a duré trois heures et demie
et a été un succès bravo lyon
je
je travaille avec lui depuis que notre
service de neuro chirurgie infantile a
été ouvert en 2013 l'un d'eux rohr
chirurgie pédiatrique c'est une
spécialité complètement différente
avant ce service n'existait pas chaque
jour des enfants tombent se cogne il ya
beaucoup de gens qui viennent nous voir
pour des traumatismes crâniens
avant je n'imagine même pas comment
l'hôpital pouvait se passer d'un service
de neurochirurgie
porter les remplacements 30 sous sa
surveillance j'ai appris beaucoup et je
continue à apprendre je lui en suis
reconnaissant
les ont fait beaucoup d'opérations à
l'hôpital mais c'est à la maison qu'ils
trouvent la concentration pour se
préparer
allons chez lui pour y voir plus clair
en principe ici c'est là où je travaille
quand je ne suis pas à l'hôpital
j'imagine que tu des opérations à
préparer ces centres la mi temps je
pourrai pas des opérations aussi par
exemple des scans à regarder c'est ici
je me concentre pour me préparer
il faut parfois à regarder et essayer
d'être assez déjà avant trajectoire ce
que tu dois faire le jour de l'opération
qui soit ils sont après puisque je suis
professeur le à l'université de médecine
et notre ville d'aytré dont jean st
lamoureux chirurgie là bas d'accord dans
un jeu où il faut se préparer quand il
ya des dépôts avait des étudiants soit
deux premières années ou bien de 4e
selon se passe une journée de travail
chez toi ou je me lève toujours très tôt
le matin je me prépare
7 45 ouais je suis déjà je suis déjà au
boulot et après la ronde du matin c'est
à 8h et en fait si j'ai bien compris en
fait c'est une partie de ta maison ici
l'an passé une partie de la famille est
toujours là parce qu'elle est toujours
sans sa famille il n'y a pas de médecine
dont la famille doit être toujours je
les prends je suis toujours à voir avec
ma famille les enfants mon épouse aussi
dont tu es une fille d'un fils de 7 ans
et une fille de 18 ans déjà en évitant
d'accord ils comprennent un petit plus
ton métier ils veulent faire leur
retrait mais je pense à mon fils qui va
faire le métier ma fille ne veut pas lui
fit si les intéressent pourquoi la
médecine et pense que tout ça dépend de
lui un jeu faussées lien ok donc ça
c'est ton ça c'est ton bureau
oui c'est sur mon deuxième bureau si je
peux le dire c'est une table à langer ça
c'est ce saint cado jim patiente
oui j'ai opéré son enfant le plus petit
bébé quel est l'âge
il en coûte pour qu'elle t'a fait une
opération le bébé avec l ajout premier
jour le premier jour ils dès la
naissance un an quelques heures quoi
faire quelques dents avait une
hydrocéphalie et aussi j'ai aussi opérer
des enfants avec les dix pilotes 10 feed
ah ah oui qu'est ce que c'est
la moelle épinière fendue c'est bien je
repensais là on dirait que c'est toi la
voilà c'est moi effectivement sera aussi
une moment j'ai opéré son enfant je
pense qu'elle avait 15 ans avait une
tumeur et spinales et de la moelle
épinière
ça s'est passé bien l'opération enfants
d'aujourd'hui n'a plus trop blâmer ses
parents qui ont fait ce portrait là dont
je m'entendais pas
est-ce que c'est plus difficile de faire
la chirurgie sur des enfants par rapport
aux adultes question qu'on me pose
toujours cette question un poste tout le
temps mais comment je vais dire aux
fêtes et la chirurgie des adultes faut
changer des adultes et pédiatriques tout
ça c'est sympa facile mais chez les
enfants c'est un peu plus un peu plus
compliqué pour pouvoir parce que leur
enfant que le diagnostic n'est pas aussi
facile que ça ne te dis jamais de quoi
ce qui ne va pas en dehors je serai prêt
à se poser un diagnostic chez les
enfants c'est un peu plus compliqué
des responsabilités aussi parce que
derrière chaque enfant il ya le p mais
est-ce que l'hôpital est bien possède
tout ce qu'il faut pour que tu
travailles au mieux aujourd'hui dans mon
hôpital j'ai payé je suis j'ai comblé
microscope pas venir aux navigations
l'endoscopie mais il ya un autre studio
est un studio chirurgie qui est dans ma
pierre moscou s'est pas toujours demandé
l'aidé il n'y a jamais de problème donc
on travaille tous un montant d'1 7
suffit de tous ou dessous de tout ce
dont il a besoin et su préserver
aujourd'hui dit que que tu connais ton
de la neurochirurgie c'est un peu ça
sera pas vrai je dis même tous les
professeurs même les plus depuis éminent
au monde entier ils vont toujours t'ai
dit que toute la vie sans crainte d'un
tank
il étudie vous mais moi aussi donc je ne
peux pas dit que voilà on a on est auto
et je m'arrête là mange tous les jours
je continue je ne fais qu'un étudiant il
ya encore beaucoup de choses à savoir
neurochirurgie
comment tu es arrivé à la chirurgie et
surtout à la chirurgie pédiatrique
je suis arrivé en charge et pourquoi pas
ce que vous faites comme ronnie
mouvement a été percutée par la moto
taxi elle a été opérée au cameroun par
un de nos chirurgiens dont déjà bien
nager qui avait étudié ici en lice y
avait le temps j'ai compris que vraiment
il nous fallait aller seulement de
chirurgie et je n'avais plus besoin de
rien moi j'ai dit que c'est ça mon truc
c'est un signal c'est un signe qui m'a
qui a changé toute ma vie puis sa maman
avait une hémiplégie à l'époque après
l'opération
sa santé est venu complètement à et
voilà j'ai décidé que voilà je fais
comme un héros chez les jets et
craignant de plus les hommes gagnent cam
est né au cameroun
abuja une petite ville située dans une
région montagneuse de l'ouest du pays
dernier d'une famille de six enfants il
est bon élève et passe brillamment son
pack scientifique au lycée général
leclerc de yaoundé la capitale du pays
impressionné par une opération
chirurgicale qui effectue sur sa mère un
chirurgien formé en russie
il décide de s'orienter vers la médecine
il part alors pour te faire sur les
traces de ce médecin qui a reçu sa
formation là bas après une première
année préparatoire consacrée à
l'apprentissage de la langue russe léon
rentrer à l'académie d'état de médecine
deux tiers il y fait son cursus de
médecine générale pendant six ans puis
se spécialise en neurochirurgie et
obtient son doctorat en 2011
à cette époque il rencontre sa femme
svetlana avec laquelle ils se marient
dès 2003 il exerce en tant que
neurochirurgien et opère des adultes à
l'hôpital régional de médecine de pierre
dix ans plus tard l'hôpital régional
pédiatrique deux tiers ouvre un
département de neurochirurgie et leon en
devient le premier chef de service
parallèlement il enseigne dans
l'université qui l'a formé petit à petit
sa réputation devient tels que des
patients lui viennent d'autres régions
du pays très attaché à la ville qui lui
a tout donné comme il aime à le dire les
on a décidé d'y rester malgré des
propositions venues de moscou ou de
saint pétersbourg
[Musique]
c'est un petit peu tous grâce à yann mon
épouse c'est la femme a enchanté bonjour
cette lan 1 et donc toi tu passes de ton
cabinet directement la le voisin normand
ouais après j chambre ici le beaucoup de
chance ça fait longtemps que vous
habitez ici où ça fait plus de dix ans
déjà
ouais et le fait que vous soyez loin du
centre ça vous dérange pas trop
on n'est pas très long 10 en dix minutes
ouais ouais ouais dix minutes comme vous
c'est le calme c'est ce que je voulais
et l'école pour son enfant elle est pas
très loin non plus n'ont pas très loin à
15 minutes en voiture c'est donc tout
est un côté 1
on va emprunter ensemble un petit et
ouais ouais d'accord sur les i
j'ai le petit garçon si jeune âge il en
77 ans comment il s'appelle français
lyon attend les élèves y est voilà
l'énigme est pas là la voie g l aller
chez une copine un le fisc et là il a
exactement
régine mary j ils comprennent un petit
peu le français je peux tout petit peu
mais plus il parle plus de riches sur la
mise en plan par lequel rue st quels
sont vos goûts vos vies vos passe-temps
toi quand tu ne travailles pas qu'est ce
que tu fais on se promène beaucoup ont
fait du shopping à 11 ans trouve en
camping aussi comme mon fils il faut
aussi nous football parfois avec un long
voyage quand ils ont des compétitions
quelque part aussi tu joue au football
c'est ça j'ai toujours aimé le football
un compte au cameroun en ce sens c'est
dans le sens c'est dans les gènes je
voulais parler aussi j'avais une
question de poser la religion je pense
que tu viens d'une famille catholique
est ce que tu pratiques ici comment ça
se passe et c'est quand je vais à
l'aigle et je vais à l'église orthodoxe
aussi ai-je une patte des différences et
comme on ferait il est il est prêtre
c'est ça être mon frère faisait lui
invoqué en photo oui il est large photo
à gauche ou à lille au cameroun il est
curé de sa paroisse voilà il est
toujours avec moi il me protège aussi
beaucoup c'est un nombre des dieux voilà
et toi ici tu vas de temps en temps a
augmenté régulièrement mager danger le
temps
très bien j'étais très bon tu voulais
préparer à manger quelque chose
continuer ne prépare quelque chose de
bon s'est investie j'essaie d'y aller
ballon vie des voix bon alors qu'est ce
que tu me prépares de bon là aujourd'hui
je fais steak de dn2 vrai voilà à leur
tour les ingrédients je vois qu'à tout
bien préparé on dit on va avoir une
opération au 7 mai j'ai vu là tous les
détails et le petit couteau le petit
jour pour jour toujours j'aime tout est
fiction un tube tu tu prépares ce moment
oui les pumas vie estudiantine
comment tu t'es habitués à la russie n'a
pas été trop dur au début
au début c'était dur parce que je venais
d'un pays où donc au cameroun il faisait
très chaud je suis arrivé ici à l'époque
en septembre il faisait déjà fois mais
avait le temps s'habitue puisque je
savais que je venais pour quelque chose
fait mes études médicales et il fallait
en outre aux croûtes étudièrent à lire
et à bout et la langue c'était pas trop
dur où la langue russe elle est
difficile est une très belle langue moi
mais je juge j'adore et qui a été bien
accueilli ici comment ça se passe
tellement mousse et j'ai été bien
accueilli quant à arriver et à mon
professeur de langues
celui qui nous a reçu à l'aéroport même
le jour prochain directement on a
commencé un tout de suite dans la partie
et pour tout de suite donc c'est parce
que là on travaille et on faisait les
riches du matin au soir
donc c'est comme ça tous les jours
[Musique]
m
avec lyon nous avons décidé de me
promener après les tares qu'à un
quartier de tiers on peut dire que c'est
une ville dans la ville
ce quartier industriel a été construit à
la fin du 19e siècle et c'est la
première expérience de conception d'un
quartier résidentiel autonome pourquoi
finalement après tout est décidé à à
c'est plutôt 2 soit deux repartis en ton
pays soit soudées lier tango le cursus
médical et en principe il amoureux
chirurgie c'est très bon signe selon
elle après sa commande il on s'habitue
re commencer on commence à aimer le pays
oui on prend même le pire
j'aime le pays depuis nos débuts en
principe comment as tu été acceptée à
l'intérieur même de l'hôpital comme
chirurgie ans comme nouveau chirurgien
ce difficile au début toujours c'est
difficile il faut faire ses preuves
il faut montrer les gens voient que
voilà tu es performant on avait le temps
et le comportement aussi ça fait
beaucoup hein quand tu es arrivé en fait
du cameroun
donc tu as tu as rita et et études
quelle était ta mentalité et comment
comment elle s'est finalement comment tu
l'a changée vis-à-vis des russes
on se dit que directement j'ai compris
comment tout fonctionne ici fonctionner
ici non c'est pour sa ville où tu en
avais là je suis tu viens quand il est
encore très jeune après le lycée et puis
la seaco logique et le caractère ça
continue à se former ici
[Musique]
quel est selon toi le trait le plus
saillant des russes gasc prix nous c'est
évident
voilà l'hospitalité il aime beaucoup
recevoir c'est ça voilà qu'est ce qui te
déplaît en russie quelque chose que que
tu vois que tu n'aimes pas je sais pas
quand il fait trop chaud et le froid le
climat j'aime la ddt
j'aime divers manèges mais parfois quand
ça mais non ça déplaît qu'est ce qui te
manque le plus enrichi pour en principe
il me manque rien
nota mourne à attention le cameroun la
veille la famille
la mise sur mon pays natal qu'est ce que
la réussite a apporté par ici m'a donné
presque toute la profession une forme
les enfants qu'il est en occupation
préféré être avec ma famille c'est la
famille leon j'ai pris beaucoup de
plaisir à passer la journée avec toi et
fière
je te souhaite une bonne continuation à
bientôt à très bientôt
merci beaucoup s'est en pris
notre émission touche à sa fin nous
avons passé un excellent moment avec
notre invité les ondes mannequin qui
nous a ouvert les portes de son hôpital
qui nous a ouvert les yeux sur la
neurochirurgie et sur celle îles
pittoresques deux tiers de nouveaux
lieux de nouvelles personnalités toutes
aussi intéressantes vous attendre je
vous dis à très bientôt sur la défense
[Musique]